ahora hablamos de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france24 rosa pérez
conmigo en el estudio rosa abrimos esta
revista de prensa con los que está
siendo la principal novedad de esta
guerra en ucrania el día de hoy la
salida de los combatientes ucranianos de
la planta metalúrgica de asof tal en la
ciudad de mariupol que es lo que está
ocurriendo rosa buenos días raúl pues
hay algunos detalles que son difíciles
de esclarecer a esta hora no aún así hay
algunos hechos que parecen bastante
claros por un lado recordemos que la
planta siderúrgica de asustar es ha sido
el último reducto de resistencia como
decías en la ciudad portuaria de
mariupol tras casi tres meses de sitio
ruso y que en esta planta siderúrgica
una de las más grandes de europa en los
bunkers hay en los túneles ademán
permanecido pues sobre todo con
combatientes del batallón a soft también
otras unidades del ejército ucraniano y
también durante muchas semanas distintos
civiles no pero como decíamos tras las
semanas de asedio finalmente ayer lunes
por la se anunció un acuerdo entre kiev
y moscú para sacar a los heridos pero
aquí es donde empieza un poco pues estas
dificultades para esclarecer lo que ha
acabado pasando porque si bien tanto un
lado como otro reportan que entre los
260 combatientes que han abandonado la
planta en estas últimas horas hay 51
heridos graves no se acaba de saber bien
bien los otros 200 en qué contexto
acaban saliendo de asof tal no ya que es
un poco lo que vamos a intentar
esclarecer empezamos con el moscú times
como decías que señala que según el
gobierno de kiev
más tarde se va a entrar en un proceso
de intercambio de estos soldados
ucranianos que han abandonado a soft al
dirigiéndose hacia territorio controlado
por rusia y también que se lentes que ha
pedido comprensión al pueblo de ucrania
tras a esta pues salida del último
bastión de resistencia en la ciudad de
mariupol y también en este mensaje que
ha mandado a través de un vídeo
difundido por su canal de tele ha pedido
a los combatientes que permanecen
todavía en la planta que prioricen
salvar sus vidas y que ucrania necesita
héroes vivos también agradeció a la cruz
roja a naciones unidas a la inteligencia
pues un poco su mediación en todo este
proceso pero el moscú times también hace
un ejercicio digamos bastante típico de
estos de contextos bélicos que es un
poco
decir asegurar que todo este sufrimiento
ha servido por algo no y es que el
ministerio de defensa de ucrania calcula
que la resistencia en mariupol impidió
que 20 mil tropas rusas se desplegarán a
otros campos de batalla y que moscú
capturar a la ciudad de sap orilla bueno
raúl este es un poco el resumen que hace
en moscú times y como habla como lo dice
como lo reseñó al yazira pues a al
yazira ya cambia un poco el verbo no
dice cientos de soldados dejan mariupol
tras rendirse ante las fuerzas rusas
pero otros soldados permanecen en la
planta siderúrgica y es que aquí lo que
decíamos no ya se señala que estos 200
soldados se han rendido en lugar de
haber sido evacua 2 como está diciendo
el mosky times porque se utiliza un
verbo u otro lo que está claro es que se
han dirigido a territorio ruso
siendo soldados ucranianos no por lo que
pues
claramente van a estar bajo captura de
las fuerzas de moscú por otro lado
también señala al yazira que las
conversaciones entre moscú y kiev para
poner fin a la guerra se han detenido
rosa y que dice el sunday times' pues el
sunday times vuelve a usar la palabra
evacuación dice la acería de as hostal
es evacuada y ucrania finaliza la misión
de combate en mariupol pero es que esta
finalización del combate el mariupol
también pues genera ciertas dudas lo
vamos a ver ahora y dice también el
sunday times' las tropas que resistieron
al asedio durante meses pueden ser
cambiadas por cautivos rusos también
pueden ser cambiadas no porque vamos a
comentar las palabras de excelencia el
respeto y pues faltan algunas
precisiones como lo trató de prensa
oficialista de rusia rosa estamos
hablando de r test book big o la agencia
tass pues mira rt dice 265 combatientes
del batallón al soft y militares
ucranianos de la planta de as hostal se
rindieron en un día informa el
ministerio ruso de defensa también según
el kremlin los 51 heridos graves que
salieron de esta planta están siendo
enviados a un hospital de novasoft en la
república popular de donges recordemos
que rusia reconoce pues a estas
repúblicas separatistas
autoproclamadas de donges y lugansk por
otro lado sputnik dice más de 250
combatientes se rinden en las últimas 24
horas y un detalle que pues hemos
querido señalar que es que mientras rt
califica el batallón a soft de grupo
nacionalista sputnik lo califica
directamente del grupo neonazi
por otro lado sputnik dice la planta de
asustar es el último lugar de
concentración de las fuerzas ucranianas
después de que la ciudad fuera liberada
en abril también pues siempre estos
términos de ocupación liberación depende
de de quien provenga el relato y la
agencia tass dice el presidente
ucraniano confirma la evacuación de
tropas de la sitiada planta de as hostal
y aquí es donde analizamos un poco las
palabras de selenski porque él si bien
dijo que la intención era este
intercambio a futuro de prisioneros de
entre los combatientes ucranianos bajo
contra el ruso y los rusos bajo control
ucraniano precisó que el intercambio de
prisioneros es delicado y toma mucho
tiempo también el kremlin señala que
ucrania ha abandonado las negociaciones
y que no ha dado respuesta respuesta al
tratado propuesto por rusia rosa pues
gracias como siempre por esta revista de
prensa del día de hoy martes nos vemos
mañana con más información más revista
de prensa ahora pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día